hi i'm heiner your next mckinsey  consultant sharing career advice so what  are the reasons why consultants leave  their job but in my experience it's both  of three reasons first it's the working  hours yes you need to work quite hard  quite often long hours in consulting  second it's the lack of operational  experience it's often a lot about the  theories and the concepts are not so  much about implementing things but then  some people miss and want to pursue  further and third it's about the  repetitiveness of certain tasks yes you  need to work a lot in powerpoint a lot  in excel and some people at some point  want to do other things don't want to  follow the typical project structure all  the time which is why they look for the  change follow for more career advice